bonsoir bouge pas alors je dis non tous
ensemble basse et la turquie
j'aime bien ce sujet mais bon il est
frais or au [ __ ]
[Applaudissements]
d'autres s'inquiètent je suis commandes
à
là
à l'image des bons c'est mohamed mohamed
sylla comme comme un maître d'ailleurs
qu'on embrasse ahmed ya bientôt social
games as tu étais libre de pizzas tu
t'es fait connaître en publiant des
clips sur youtube c'est ou fès et c'est
sain c'est un destin parce que tu
utilises ouest quand j'ai vu ça je me
suis dit le talent mine de rien ça paye
toujours ce qu'il a un talent
exceptionnel et c'était obligé que tu
sois tu so to phone star wars ça ça
arrive à un moment où je m'y attendais
pas moi j'étais en train de livrer mes
quatre fromages et en même temps mettre
de côté je faisais j'écrivais mes textes
faisant un peu de musique et par hasard
j'ai fait une vie de quinze secondes que
j'aimais sur les réseaux et à partir de
là bas c'est à dire qu'il a inventé un
style de musique
oui n'en déplaise à guy chevrette
zemmour par exemple c'est que grâce à
lui la france rayonne partout dans le
monde parce que partout dans l'ue dont
on connaît mhd alors justement si tu
pouvais appeler damien si la wii hd
parce que malgré ces mohamed il faut que
tu fasses dmn dame des neiges
oui c'est une vraie chance pas tant pour
les jeunes d'aujourd'hui grâce à
internet ya plus de talents ignorés
maintenant parce qu'on ne tombera pas
vous non mais lui aussi la fin de vie
des otages seconde a pour se lancer
heureusement ça n'a jamais ça n'a jamais
pris le talent peuvent poster des vidéos
ils expriment leur voilà leur talent
quand il chante on danse et on se fait
remarquer mme attend toujours ses
problèmes que le week-end c'est que vous
n'avez pas beaucoup d'arrivées l'a dit
ça accroche beaucoup c'est vrai c'est
comme apple crocs des sondes album
s'appelle 19 et vont bien sûr il
s'arrête il faut je pense que c'est
presque déjà complet donc allé dire
franchement aller vite parce qu'il reste
peu de place ces voix lasse et je sais
que tout le monde va aller le voir ici
c'est la folie est tombé bob s'appelle
19 parce qu'à 19 sites de dons ou
simplement que tu fais chier tu sais que
le site 19,7 rude où est ton album est
sorti donc 19 10 le 19 septembre
tu as grandi dans le 19e et peut-être
thème le chiffre 19,3 19,9 aussi c'est
ce qu'on verra à pécho 19,9 dans ta vie
c'est ce qu'on m'a dit non je sais je
sais comme merci en tout cas d'être là
j'ai vu que tu allais tu as dit que tu
allais faire un petit break ça m'a pas
en quoi c'est ça ouais c'est vrai ou pas
c'est vrai je les mets sur mes réseaux
et ge
j'étais un peu j'étais un peu fatigué
j'ai envie de musique envie de cette vie
de star je voulais vraiment être dans
l'anonymat en fait vraiment être
tranquille
faire ma vie quoi donc là tu as envie de
faire ta vie pendant un an mais les gens
vont pas tout lire et on parle anglais
mais je me cachais ah c'est vrai ouais
alors si tu veux venir à la maison c'est
exceptionnel que tu fais voilà je
voulais le dire encore et je suis très
très fan de toi et 29 mars à l'accord
hôtel arena de paris bercy
elle a 24 ans elle m'avait dit ça fait
déjà c'est vrai que ça fait des dames on
a l'impression qu'il a une carrière de
vérité francis cabrel